we may be trapped on this world that's
on the brink of mass extinction but
while we're here at least we have each
other you wear matching costumes and
compete in fashion show feeling people
think we're weird what the [ __ ] are you
doing in our bathroom no what are my
dudes we're aliens get him the [ __ ] out
of here
we're unlikable aren't we is it the
sci-fi stuff
do I smell bad what is it a little extra
effort I think we can up our likability
are you ready to do what it takes you
mean sex stuff that's possible
yeah then yes oh my god I can feel my
life
everything stopped this is [ __ ] I've
been living here for 30 years so we
never have any sci-fi [ __ ]
I've had enough [ __ ] these guys guys
want to do hair
[Music]
is that the Children's Hospital yeah you
don't really think of them blowing up
like that I mean what are they storing
giant tanks a flammable liquid now let's
get out of here before we get arrested
for all this [ __ ] with a different
microphone